,
AND -- THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
HOPE YOU ARE READY FOR MORE OUT
OF CONTROL RADICAL POLICIES.
DEMOCRATS BARELY KEPT CONTROL
THE SENATE WITH THE WIN IN
NEVADA AND NOW THEY THINK THEY
NEED A MANDATE TO SHOVE THEIR
OUTRAGEOUS PROGRESSIVE POLICIES
DOWN OUR THROATS.
>> THIS VICTORY BELONGS TO
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS WHO
FOUGHT FOR WORKING PEOPLE.
THE THINGS WE DID WERE IMPORTANT
AND POPULAR.
>> JOE BIDEN -- SUPPORT AND
AGENDA WERE THE THINGS WE NEEDED
IN THIS COUNTRY, AND THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE VOTED FOR.
>> I PREDICTED YOUNG PEOPLE
WOULD VOTE FOR US.
WHY?
WE FOCUSED ON CLIMATE, WHICH --
REALLY CARE ABOUT.
>> NO QUESTION THAT THIS WOULD
BE THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN DECADES.
>> BUT DO WE NOT REALIZE THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE STILL EXPECTED TO
LOSE THE HOUSE?
MAYBE THE LIBERAL CHEERLEADERS
NEED TO LISTEN TO THE GUY THEY
ARE PRAISING.
>> President Biden: I THINK WE
WILL GET CLOSE TO THE HOUSE --
BUT VERY CLOSE.
>> EVEN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
THINKS IT WOULD'VE BEEN WORSE IF
BIDEN HAD EMERGED -- ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> IT IS SUCH A GOOD NIGHT FOR
HIM.
HOWEVER, IT SEEMS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT EXIT POLLS, DEMOCRATS
PREVAIL IN SPITE OF HIM, NOT
NECESSARILY -- 49% OF VOTERS
SAID THEY SOMEWHAT DISAGREE WITH
HIM, VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS, 45%.
HE HAS SET OFF ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, WASN'T MAKING THE BIG
CAMPAIGN PUSHES, FRONT AND
CENTER.
>> DO DEMOCRATS HAVE A MANDATE?
WHAT IS IT?
>> TO CONTINUE GOVERNING.
SOMETHING OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS.
THIS WAS AN INCREDIBLY
GOOD NIGHT FOR DEMOCRATS THAT
WERE THEN EXPECTED TO TURN
AROUND AND SAY "WE ARE SO
TERRIBLE."
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
THEY SAID REPUBLICANS,
ESPECIALLY ONES WHO DENIED THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION, OR ARE
ALIGNED WITH DONALD TRUMP THAT
YOU ARE SO TERRIBLE.
IT'S A LOOK LIKE AT THE CLEAR
POLITICS PROJECTIONS.
THE G.O.P. WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
SITTING ON 54 SEATS RIGHT NOW.
49, AND WE HAVE A GOOD CHANCE OF
TAKING GEORGIA AS WELL.
PEOPLE GOT THIS WILDLY WRONG.
I THINK IT IS UNFAIR FOR ANYONE
TO THINK -- FOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD
DEFIANT HISTORICAL EXPECTATIONS
SHOULD THEN TURN AROUND AND BOW
DOWN TO A PARTY THAT MANAGED TO
BUNGLE SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
I UNDERSTAND KEVIN McCARTHY
WILL BE CHALLENGED FOR THE
LEADERSHIP.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE ELSE CAN
GET OVER THE 50% THERE, BUT
THERE IS NO WAY MITCH
McCONNELL AND KEVIN McCARTHY
MANAGE THIS WELL.
THERE WERE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
PATTY MURRAY WAS IN HER SEAT.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
>> DO IOU MONEY?
HOW MUCH?
>> YOU OWE ME $100 AND GERALDO
$1,000 PAID >> THERE YOU GO.
I'M NOT SURE IF I WILL PAY HIM,
BUT THERE IS $100 FOR YOU.
>> THAT'S FANCY.
>> LET'S GET OVER PAID >>
VICTORY!
>> STOP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DO THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING "WE ARE THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE?"
COUNTRY DIDN'T MOVE FOR A MORE
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> THEY ARE TAKING THIS AS A
MANDATE.
THE WAY JESSICA SEES IT IS THE
WAY DEMOCRATS SEE IT, THAT IT IS
A MANDATE.
THIS WILL BE THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE NEXT TWO YEARS THAT
WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
THAT IS GREAT FOR 2024.
WHAT'S CRAZY IS THAT YOU HAVE
ONE OF THE MOST UNPOPULAR
PRESIDENTS IN THE HISTORY.
YOU'VE GOT INCREDIBLE PROBLEMS
WITH INFLATION, WITH THE
ECONOMY, WITH AFGHANISTAN.
EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
HAS BEEN A NIGHTMARE.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT WON THE
SELECTION FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
YOUNG PEOPLE CAME OUT AND VOTED.
THEY GOT PAID, THEY GOT THEIR
STUDENT LOANS PAID BACK.
IT WAS A BUYOUT!
THE OTHER THING IS ABORTION.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT ABORTION.
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T DO ABORTION.
ABORTION JUST FELL OUT OF THIS
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
IT WAS IN MAY OR JUNE OF THIS
YEAR, AND THAT WAS IT.
THAT'S ALL THE DEMOCRATS NEEDED.
THEY WILL BEAT THEIR CHEST AND
"IT'S BECAUSE WE ARE SO GREAT.
JOE BIDEN, WHAT A LEADER," AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> DUE MEMBER IN 2018 --
>> I DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING.
>> DONALD TRUMP FOR REPUBLICAN
PARTY ADDED SEATS IN THE U.S.
SENATE AND LOST ABOUT 40 IN THE
HOUSE.
THEY DID BETTER THAN THOSE
MIDTERMS THAN BIDEN DID IN
THESE.
>> YOU COULD ARGUE AND IT'S A
CLEAR ARGUMENT THAT REPUBLICAN'S
ARE BETTER OFF NOW THAT THEY
HAVE A HOUSE, SO IS THAT A
MANDATE?
I DON'T KNOW, BUT -- WHAT JUDGE
IS SAYING IS CORRECT.
THE HISTORIC MOMENTS WASN'T THE
SELECTION.
IT WAS ROE V. WADE BEING
OVERTURNED.
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING THAT
THE DAMS ARE STILL GOING TO LOSE
THE HOUSE.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN WORSE, BUT
IT WASN'T.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT
EXPENDED THE POLITICAL CAPITAL
THAT WAS BUILT FOR DECADES TO
OVERTURN ROE V. WADE.
THAT WAS BAKED INTO THE CAKE.
THE HILL AT THE RIGHT CHOSE TO
DIE ON WAS ROE V. WADE, AND THIS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE RIGHT TIME
TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY'VE STILL
GOT THE HOUSE.
WE DON'T KNOW, BUT THIS IS AN
ACHIEVEMENT.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF BUILDING
POLITICAL POWER IF YOU DON'T
SPEND IT?
THAT IS WHAT MADE THIS SO CLOSE.
IF YOU ARE A CONSTITUTIONALIST
AND A PRO-LIFER, YOU SHOULD BE
VERY HAPPY AND STEPPING BACK
AFTER THE SELECTION AND GOING
"THAT DIDN'T GO AS GOOD AS I
WANTED, BUT ROE V. WADE OVERTURN
AND --" WILLING TO DIE ON THE
HILL, BECAUSE THAT'S MADE OF
MILLIONS OF UNBORN CHILDREN, SO
I SHOULD BE WILLING TO FIGHT FOR
THAT LONG-TERM, SHORT-TERM,
DECADES.
IF YOU ARE JUST LOOKING TOO
CLOSE AT THE TREES, YOU ARE NOT
SEEING THE FOREST.
JESSICA IS RIGHT.
HE SAID IT LAST WEEK.
THIS IS ABOUT ABORTION.
EVERYBODY TAKES IT SERIOUSLY,
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE THAT TOOK
FOUR DECADES TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
THERE MAY BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ONGOING,
BUT THE THING IS, THERE'S GOING
TO BE PART OF REPUBLICANS THAT
SAY "SO WHAT?"
THIS IS WHEN YOU HAVE TO EXPEND
THAT CAPITAL, SO WHAT IS THE
POINT OF BEING A POLITICAL
PARTY?
>> THAT WAS A VERY GOOD
ANALYSIS.
I HAD NOT THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
THAT WAY.
SO JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CAMPAIGN
FOR ANYBODY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
HIS POLITICAL CAPITAL?
>> THINK THEY JUST HAD A GOOD
STRATEGY IN 2020, USED COVID AS
AN EXCUSE IN THAT CAMPAIGN.
HE DID NOT BOTHER HIM WHEN HE
WAS CAMPAIGNING IN DELAWARE AND
MARYLAND AND NEW YORK.
I THINK PRO-LIFE PEOPLE VOTE
TOO.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF THE STATE
REFERENDUMS THAT HAPPEN.
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR OF OHIO.
THERE ARE SOME STRICT ABORTION
RESTRICTIONS IN OHIO.
HE WON, AND SODA --
SORRY, NOT RICK SCOTT --
>> RON DeSANTIS.
IN FLORIDA, WON BIG TIME AS A
GOVERNOR IN FLORIDA.
GEORGIA, BRIAN KEMP.
THE ABORTION ISSUE WAS MORE
COMPLICATED FOR REPUBLICANS IN
THE NEW ENGLAND STATES IN
PARTICULAR, AND ALSO NEW
MICHIGAN.
>> WISCONSIN.
THERE WAS A GENERAL -- IN
MICHIGAN, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY HAD
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN WAS
STUDENTS LINED UP, UP AND DOWN
THE BLOCK, WHICH -- A REFERENDUM
LIKE THAT COULD DRIVE PEOPLE TO
THE POLLS.
JIM MESSINA, A DEMOCRATIC GUY
FOR OBAMA, WAS ON HER SHOW AT
NEWSROOM AND SAID "IF I HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT, I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THE REFERENDUMS
ARE ON THE LEO STATES IN 2024."
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SENATE,
THERE'S 33 SEATS UP, AND 24 THE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE ON THE
DEFENSE.
WE WILL HAVE TO CONSIDER THAT
GOING FORWARD.
I WILL ALSO SAY, THE REPUBLICANS
MIGHT BE DISAPPOINTED, BUT THEY
DID WIN GOOD THINGS.
THEY KEPT GOVERNORS RACES THAT
WERE IMPORTANT TO THEM.
THEY INCREASED WITH LATINOS,
ASIAN AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS.
YOU WILL NOT WIN ALL THOSE
GROUPS ALL AT ONCE, BUT THEY
FOUND A FOOTHOLD AND CONTINUE TO
GAIN THERE.
I THINK THEY WILL DO THAT, AND I
ALSO THINK THERE IS NOT GOING TO
BE A MANDATE FOR EITHER SIDE.
I THINK THERE WILL BE GRIDLOCK.
>>